I'm Steve Harvey stand-up comedian
Entertainer television host family man
but most importantly I happen to be a
man of Faith now let's stop right there
you see a mosque this is a house of
worship a house of God more non-muslims
not yet Muslims and obviously not yet
Muslims because everyone has the
potential to submit their will to the
creator of the heavens and earth that's
what a Muslim is and Steve Harvey he's
wearing this is a cultural thing so he's
behind in front of a house of worship
House of God this is where Muslims go to
pray to the one God the same God as
Jesus Moses Abraham and all the
messengers that God Almighty sent they
prayed like Muslims pray in this mosque
you know you could pray outside the moss
in the mosque but it's more rewarding in
the mosque where you all you come
together so we encourage people to visit
Moss if you enjoyed this short clip
visit the dean show TV on YouTube to
watch the full video